he got smashed from access today we have
our hands on the brand-new one +7 Pro
this is one pluses most expensive device
but what do we look at all of the specs
all the features and then we look at the
price it packs a lot of punch for the
money I was really surprised how loadly
priced it we're gonna be comparing this
new device to the s10 plus and the
iPhone 10's max two of its biggest
rivals that cost a lot more money we're
gonna compare a bunch of stuff including
the display quality the performance the
UI or the snappiness the cameras we're
gonna look at different specs the price
points and see which phone is the most
worth it for the money let's jump right
into it and do our signature fast
unboxing and there you go let's give you
my first impressions the buds land in
the perfect place for my hands over here
I have your little physical switch so
you can silence the phone or put into
vibrate mode you can customize that the
power button is right here as well so I
can literally press down or change my
settings and on the other side I have
the volume rocker where my index finger
is it's a little bit hard to press but
everything lands perfectly and we don't
have any big speed button or anything
like that even though the sn+ is a
smaller device it's not as tall as you
can see the power button is way up high
and I literally have to shift my grip of
the phone to reach it whereas with one
plus I don't have to do that at all it's
perfect and then with the iPhone let's
hold it in there you're perfect right
where my finger is say anything with the
volume rocker and then I can access that
physical switch as far as size the S 10
plus is slightly taller than the 10s max
but the tennis max is slightly wider
when we add in the new 1 + 7 Pro it is
definitely the tallest and it's probably
very similar to tennis max as far as
with maybe slightly wider actually
comparing the backs of the phones they
all look very nice very premium they're
all using glass but surprisingly the
oneplus got away with just having the
one plus logo on there
the name and then the IMEI number
instead of having a bunch of serial
numbers a little recycling logo all that
stuff the samsung has on it really takes
away from kind of the clean look where
Apple literally just
zap logo and iPhone the oneplus
definitely reminds me of an iPhone style
of design especially with the way the
camera is set up both s 10-plus and the
1 + 7 pro have triple cameras whereas
the iPhone just has a dual camera both
atenas Max and s10 Plus have
front-facing cameras we have a notch on
the iPhone a cutout with sn+ but the
oneplus 7 pro has neither of those I
know the screens not on yet but we're
gonna cover cameras just a little bit
later and the S 10 plus is the only
phone out of the bunch that still
retains a headphone jack the iPhone
comes with a 5 watt charger out of the
box very slow and if you want to get
fast charging you have to buy a special
cable and a power delivery charger the
stem plus comes with a 15 watt quick
charger included in the box but the
Snapdragon version does not support USB
C power delivery whereas the oneplus 7
pro comes with oneplus as proprietary
warp charging which is a 30 watt charger
it can charge the huge battery in this
phone to 50% in just 20 minutes it's
very fast very efficient doesn't heat up
the phone very much but unfortunately if
you're not using this proprietary
charger with 1 + s special cable or
there car charger you're not going to
get that speed and it will only charge
at 7 watts no matter what you plug it in
so you have to make sure if you want
fast charging anything above 7 watts
that you keep this on hand alright so
here we are at the home screen of the 1
plus 7 and I have to say it is nice not
having any notches or any cutouts just a
little bit ago we were praising the
cutouts compared to apples notch that
has or other Android notches but of
course if we have a full display without
anything there it is really nice to look
at as I mentioned earlier I'm not a huge
fan of curved screen edges and that had
me kind of disappointed when I saw that
one + switch to this kind of a design
but holding in my hand there just
looking at the device I really can't
tell that it's curved I mean maybe
slightly if I try to look for it
compared to the Samsung where it has a
much steeper curve angle and it just is
actually curved right at the edge where
the oneplus starts out a limit early err
and it has a smoother kind of curve so
I'm glad they went that route now as far
as bezels the tennis max has an even
better all-around but at the bottom it
is the
then goes the 1 plus 7 and the sm+ is
slightly thicker looking at the sides
the s10 plus is the thinnest and then
going the other direction and then at
the top the 1 plus actually has the
thinnest or smallest bezel now let's
talk about that 90 Hertz display refresh
rate all these phones use OLED displays
and typically all ads are stuck at about
60 but this is the first phone to have
an OLED at 90 Hertz and I could
definitely tell from the very GetGo
during the setup process just having
that extra refresh rate makes everything
super smooth I'm not seeing like motion
blur if you're used to like night pad
Pro if you've seen that where like a
gaming monitor you know what I'm talking
about
and along with the display resolution
and oneplus is really fast animations it
makes this thing super snappy I mean
they're snappy before but this just adds
like another level to it check out this
120 frames per second comparison but I
think this is the only way I can
actually relay the difference in
smoothness by showing you guys this clip
slow down comment below and let me know
what you think if you could tell a
difference in this comparison now
underneath that 90 Hertz screen we have
the fingerprint sensor just like with
the s10 plus with the iPhone we have
face ID let's go and compare the speeds
okay that's not terrible on the SN plus
definitely faster than when it came out
Samsung I think made a little bit
quicker the oneplus uses an optical
scanner and one interesting thing is if
the screen is off it will not read your
fingerprint the screen has to be turned
on so you have to either press on the
side and down double tap and then down
or if you lift up your phone or if you
flip it if you pull out of your pocket
it actually lights up the screen and
then you can kind of press down so as
you guys can see that is crazy fast now
let's take a look at the cameras this is
the best camera package that oneplus has
ever put into their phones oneplus has
usually kind of suffered in this area
but they're making big strides and the
biggest thing that I want to take a look
at is the front-facing selfie camera
that is now motorized to give us that
beautiful display without any cutouts or
notches let's flip it up and there you
go that is very very cool very feature
ristic I'm gonna take a selfie and you
guys let us know which one looks the
best and the side-by-side comparison now
one plus if you guys get that fun does
not have any beauty filters enabled like
the Samsung does out of the box so that
is very nice and if we take a look at
the back we also have triple cameras
just like the s10 plus and we're gonna
be doing a separate video getting into
that because there's so much to cover we
have night modes we have you know really
good dynamic range with the HDR photos
we have video make sure you guys to
subscribe to see that detailed camera
comparison now let's go ahead and
compare the display quality's all of
these phones use OLED displays the
oneplus actually has the highest
resolution but it's also the largest and
because that the pixel per inch is
really really close to the s 10 plus and
iPhone actually falls behind just a
little bit in terms of pixel per inch so
at this point what all adaptive and auto
brightness shut off with true tone shut
off the iPhone is the brightest followed
by the oneplus in the sm+ is just
slightly behind the oneplus and another
weird thing is that the oneplus is
actually more contrast II and as more
saturation compared to the Samsung and
that's what the natural settings that I
selected Samsung usually has a bunch of
pop and its colors and I think they've
tone that down just a little bit but all
the phones look fantastic I have a 4k
60hz our video opened up here on all
three phones the brightnesses are maxed
out and we're gonna compare the image
quality and the quality of the HDR let's
go ahead and start playing this and
right off the bat I'm noticing something
that is very very interesting
as far as watching HDR videos the
Samsung is definitely in the lead it not
only has a ton of detail the darks are
very dark lots of contrast the brights
are ultra bright they really really pop
the colors are great the iPhone is
definitely behind not as much contrast
not as much colors the brights are
definitely not as bright and the s7 plus
is in last place the brights are def
brought down really really low it just
doesn't look as good the whole image
looks really dark even though I do have
the brightness all the way turned up so
I'm really hoping that this is gonna get
fixed in the future it seems like maybe
it's just not reading the HDR video file
properly I'm
crossing my fingers because other than
watching this everything else looks
great but here everything is just really
dark and really flat so now that we
watched some video let's do a speaker
comparison I'm very excited to test out
how the oneplus 7 pro does this has
always been a weak point for the oneplus
devices we're gonna start out with the
tennis max then jump to the sm plus and
then the oneplus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so in my opinion just looking
straight at the device without doing any
sort of copying the seven Pro is not as
loud as the iPhone and it's missing some
of the high notes the crisp little high
notes that the S tendon has that I
really like about the s10 now it is
personal preference I like very sharp
eyes and this seems like it's just kind
of muted it seems like it's a little bit
quieter than the iPhone as well an
iPhone is quieter and has less of the
high-end in kind of the mids compared to
the SS 10 plus so as far as speakers
it's definitely not bad it's a huge step
up from the single speaker from the 60
and a lot of other Android phones so
it's not a bad dual stereo speaker
system but it definitely doesn't compete
with sn+ so I'm running and 2 2 so we
can compare the performance of these
devices and I am very shocked with the
volume when this video is playing it's
much louder than it was in YouTube
sighted off there's any compatibility
issues with the YouTube app because the
HDR didn't look correct and the sound
wasn't very loud I was just expecting
that just to be the speakers but in
antutu it is much louder and very loud
for a smart phone so I will be looking
into this more and I'll cover it in my
full review then - - results are in and
the winner is the 1 + 7 Pro both the
overall score if we look at every
individual category it actually wins out
other than graphics where it's basically
the same as sn+ of course these do have
the same processors the 1 + 7 Pro and
the Samsung S 10 + have almost identical
scores because they have the same
processors they both have a gigabytes of
RAM is very very close here the iPhone
actually has a slightly higher
multi-core score but about 35 to 40
percent higher single core score and
that leads us to kind of our conclusion
if we look at all the features we look
at the performance we look at the specs
the oneplus 7 really delivers that
finger
scanner is super fast the performance is
great the display is really nice the
speaker sound good I'm not sure what's
going on with YouTube but we will figure
that out and the price tag comes in at
$700 for this model 256 gigabytes of
storage 8 gigs of ram top align
processor very nice display but look at
the s10 plus that is $1000 with 128
gigabytes of storage and if you want
more you have to jump all the way up to
512 where's the iPhone for $1,100 you
get four gigs of ram which it still does
a good job with and then you get 64
gigabytes of storage and you have to
spend 1250 if you want to go up to 256
$700 or a thousand 250 for the same
amount of storage now there are some
downsides we do not have wireless
charging you can get superfast charging
but you have to use the proprietary
cable we don't have an IP waterproofing
rating but a couple videos on YouTube
have shown that it definitely is
water-resistant and the choice is kind
of up to you guys do you want to have a
name brand flagship with maybe a couple
of extras or do you want the oneplus 7
Pro which is more expensive than any
other oneplus device but now it
basically is a flagship killer all the
way around let us know which one would
be your choice down in the comment
section below if you guys want to see
more videos like this one click that
little circle above I will be switching
to one plus seven and then doing a full
review so you guys don't want to miss
out that so enables notifications if you
guys want to see more videos we have a
couple right over here this has been max
max tech and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]